un réseau de trafic humain en volant des
Cubains pour des opérations militaires
russes en Ukraine c'est ce que dénonce
la Havane dans un communiqué publié ce
lundi
les autorités cubaines s'efforcent de
neutraliser et de démanteler un réseau
de trafic d’être humain qui opèrent à
partir de la Russie pour incorporer des
citoyens cubains dans les forces
militaires impliquées dans les
opérations militaires en Ukraine
La Havane indique avoir engagé des
poursuites pénales contre les personnes
impliquées soulignant son rejet
catégorique du mercenaria elle rappelle
que Cuba ne participe pas à la guerre en
Ukraine
se communiquer paraît quelques jours
après la publication par un journal
américain de deux témoignages
d'adolescents qui affirment d'avoir été
recrutés par l'armée russe
officiellement pour travailler sur des
chantiers en Ukraine
mes hommes et dernier un journal russe
annonçait déjà que plusieurs cubains
avaient signé pour aller se battre en
échange d'une promesse de citoyenneté
russes
la Russie entretient depuis longtemps
une relation étroite avec Cuba la guerre
en Ukraine a encore rapproché ces deux
alliés alors que Moscou est isolé sur la
scène internationale mais cette affaire
risque de tendre leur relation
de ce côté la Russie n'a pas encore
réagi aux accusations de trafic d'êtres
humains